[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation this was
voted put out a community post that Roxy
and Greg were going to meet up today and
I had a fourth option there of just to
go what we're feeling before it's time
to film but I already saw what was
taking the lead and it was the one that
I was leaning towards as well Roxy what
are we watching today as above so below
boom is that right yeah you nailed it
homie can I tell them what we did what
did we do we took a really dope picture
here it is yeah this is the way to show
it now we wanted to post with the poll
but you can't post a picture with the
poll no apparently not how many takes
did it take us it took us an obnoxious
amount to get that right but ladies and
gentlemen thank you for voting on this
I'm excited to do it please go ahead
leave a like on this video you know how
it goes and also subscribe click the
notification Bell a lot of reactions
coming up here Rox is doing a bunch as
well yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel the
I feel the
energy also guys look my G fuel drink
you guys know how much I love g-u fuel
I'm drinking it all the time you guys
know they're more than just some brand
we work with they're my life my religion
and now there're embracing spooky season
they got this nightmare on Elm Street
themed one they also have a Chucky
themed one they got a horror themed
drinks I shot them out more than I'm
required to because that's how much I
stand by how much they help me get
through each and every single day and
I'm on this no sugar added diet and
there's no sugar in it yet I feel full
of life you know how much I love this
stuff I know you do and I also know you
really are on that no sugar life because
I try to bake you things and you don't
eat them you only do your G fuel I know
I S no thanks to the cookie I got my Gap
fuel right here use our promo code in
the the descri description box and pin
comment and get yourself 20% off select
tubs let's get to
it oh yeah totally forgot to mention
fooling through at and watch along reck
with their own copy available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
thank you again for all who have been
joining you do that above and below yeah
I I know as I was talking you were
looking like right at me I'm like she's
going to say something and I don't know
what she's going to say I was trying to
think of the whole time some kind of pun
cuz the title I feel like as above so
below I should have thought of a bunch
but I haven't thought of it yet so I'll
give it to you in the actual reaction
all right or give it to me in the
comments don't give it to me give as
above let's watch the movie oh why is it
rated R there's [__] in it r is for
[Music]
Roxy r is for
reg as in
Greg R is for horror R he could have did
the O the O the r o wait are we doing
your name what are we doing it's the R
rating yeah could the I lost track of
the
bit it's found footage that's right yes
the whole movie mhm yes where are we
just crossed the Iranian border on route
to the habala region where they've
ordered the destruction of a network of
caves by Sundown M these caves might
contain a critical missing piece of our
history I enter this country of my own
free will fully knowing that the
punishment for trespassing here is
burial up to your neck and sand jeez
we'll be quick
okay wow we are getting right to
it
a lot of found footage are done on a lot
of worse cameras this is a pretty a
solid camera she has yeah I know it's I
don't know how they're being
inconspicuous with this kind of camera
yeah oh my God oh my God you know if
they when you do found footage do they
rig you
up uh apparently this looks rigged right
this looks like a GoPro on the shoulder
or something
what what are you doing they're going to
blow it up
anyway I can't think straight this thing
on my head okay I was R there's
something that I like about how
immediate this
is I don't know why but in my head I
just keep
hearing I know it's there's a bit of an
archaeological vibe to it she is Tomb
rating whoa I can't how big that is I
mean it looks really big you know what
this is oh
my
key she say it's what's key Scarlet key
in roxxy's defense I also don't know
what she say for everyone's like she
asked too many
questions I do listen I have a question
to ask her have been my whole life in
every scenario it's not because I think
you know the answers I just want to ask
I appreciate
that
oh whoa oh
no oh she going to be trapped down
there taking shaky cam to the next
level Greg I'm thinking this
is the So Below
part come
over come
on interesting sound design Choice the
sound design is quite effective and it's
I like how this is very reliant on it
this one
sequence yo you're doing a great job at
like placing your camera in the right
spots yeah you must be more careful oh
no he's about to turn on her was a path
to Madness oh she's awaking something my
father wasn't crazy everyone who hunts
for fls don't is is crazy they all wind
up
dead how far will you
go that was a cool way to do the title
my name is Scarlet Marlo and I'm a
professor at University College London I
have a PhD in urban archaeology oh she
is like an archaeologist okay I'm also
fluent in four spoken languages and two
dead ones I am a black belt in Krav mcar
oh nice that's a lot of degrees for
someone your age my father insisted
um she's aiming to make her dad proud oh
no it's the the
um just Craig you just had me watch the
movie dude you just had me watch the
movie from Purge yes yes oh the guy who
theyve took in I I am to beat him
something Harge the creation of the
stone was the goal of alchemy which was
a early form of science which studied
transformation in all its forms and my
father was actually the world's
preeminent historian me I don't
know is there any truth to that why cuz
he himself oh oh man she's going she's
going to go down the same path as her
dad that's he went crazy this is
Nicholas fingal's Tombstone the clues to
the location of the philosopher stone
were encoded somehow in these I
discovered the fabled rose key Rosetta
Stone used for translating alchemical
symbols into Aramaic oh nice
unfortunately I don't speak luckily I
know a guy who does you didn't speak
aromatic they people learned how to
speak it for Passion of the Christ do a
lingo
baby I stole your back George I know
you're
here oh that's make me dizzy how are you
already yeah well oh my God if you throw
up on camera be good for views please I
don't think so The Purge last time we
were together I literally wound up in a
Turkish prison George I'm sorry well
Chase your lead see how far that gets
you it's funny cuz this is like a
Hollywood script whereas most found
footage really goes for realism yeah
that raw feeling yeah this is like a
real Hollywood Scream the combination of
that is kind of throwing me off a little
bit I found the rose key George I knew
it and I need your help translating the
Aramaic cuz she doesn't speak got to get
back with him by yourself doesn't matter
you went you're a lunatic
kiss sleep together
kiss go go go come on come
on you okay Benji yeah yeah I'm good
okay the benefit of shooting for cheap
with found footage allows you to
actually go to these really cool
locations that's what I was just
thinking like they really spent their
money on these locations yeah yeah hear
in their church bells ring for the first
time in 284
years damn you fix that by yourself
little
grease I you
translate but that's it we're definitely
going to see the bone right yeah that
documentarian is a perv sword is lime
okay and what about the key no key
there's no key no why is there no key I
don't know so if he's carrying the key
on his back does that mean that the key
is on his back it's on the back of the
of the tombstone so I need to have a
look behind it no it's a metaphorical
key I need oh my God what damn bold I
can't we're going to have to put it down
this is a really bad call you can't do
that yeah I'm surprised he's down for it
respect the museum ammonia sulphonate
distilled with lime what are you
doing okay you don't want to breathe
this in what is it she said exactly what
it was can I repeat what it is and
no I I need some matches matches no no
not this is so fun this is a fullon like
movie
movie okay that's pretty cool you don't
want to breathe this in she is right up
to it yeah
wow get your camera winged vulture leads
the way with brightest light in Darkest
Day that's the Green Lantern
Monro halfway Twix the darkest gate and
this tablet laid a top a parid fate
Everyone likes to rhyme I I uh I do it
all the time it's interesting that
they're rhyming in English in not
England yeah it's true night sky right
on the tablet yes good okay so darkest
gate darkest gate you find your fate if
you run too late past eight the gates of
hell right the Gates of Hell okay
halfway between this grave and the gates
of hell no no no wait wait I have my dad
oh [__] they're going to find the actual
Gates of Hell in this movie Alchemists
believed that the number of the devil
was 741 then it makes sense that they
would think that hell was 741 ft beneath
the surface of the Earth right why 741 5
ft beneath flamel's Tombstone is where
we'll find the stone to split the
difference how are we supposed to get
370 ft into the Earth the catacombs
we're in Paris there are over 200 mil of
tunnels right underneath our feet oh my
God they're going to go through the
Paris catacombs did they shoot this at
the actual Paris catacombs catacombs
don't go under flamel's grave but if we
borrowed through this wall here no you
can't oh my god look how enticed he is
by her I like him I know can't wait for
him to die was so hurtful sorry to break
it to he's gonna die I can't wait for
her to die she'll probably die too I
don't want her to die until they hook
up stop this is the Empire of the Dead
patterns and Crosses but they made you
know what I like about this a lot of the
time in these kind of movies I'm like
what a bunch of videot why do this but
it is making me as an audience go I
would love to explore all this I hear
you totally seriously Scarlet this is
creeping me
out that should be so fun to see
basically need to
go about half a mile through the school
we need to find a way into the off
limits area of the Catacombs oh my God
Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny
kind of ripped this off what year was
this uh like 12 years ago or something
he'll bring you please thanks come back
into the group please come on
sorry who was this thanks for nothing is
that a ghost
maybe what the hell was that damn she
fast parisians are
fast are these people drugged up they
also spent their money on Extras whoa
did you see that little reflection that
was cool I
did love this documentarian is not
speaking up about the
catacombs I know who
is okay why would I want to bring him
down there and he doesn't have that
accent we have found a secret tunnel in
the catacombs that no one else knows
about I know that place we would have
found it if it was there because it was
designed years and years ago to be
invisible damn these are some sexy ass
explorers yeah all French people are hot
you didn't know that I did not know that
and she's not French well anyone not
American if it's true me and my friends
can we take half of the treasure you can
have all of the treasure it's not what
I'm looking for half is half is
fine so you'll take us yes I said okay
try these oh my goodness he looks like
like Rider Strong guys meet my team hi
this is Zed our climber and this is
sui Now's the Time to fight guys she
looks like a baby CR Silverman a little
bit Yeah there's water too here so
prepared for that we have enough
equipment and yeah yeah we got
everything de right shows it's character
trait to show just how far he's willing
to go do you know how he got the scar on
his hand do you want to know how I got
these scars let me do Den
Ro [__] man
[__] very good dairo do it do dairo he's
my favorite
yo they're doing a good job of making me
care about these characters fast that
was the first time we just got to like
hang out with their personalities you
know like I would be homies with them
let's grab a beer I like soxy cuz she's
Roxy but socky can we keep
going
just had to take the time to mark
that I think you're were trying to say
the name aldus Hodes oh that that sounds
right but that's not him no yeah no hot
what's the guy from from what's it
called called was the movie you have you
watch
Purge I don't know yeah some your heads
hold there it is that is not the same
actor now that angle he looked very
different right c c check I'm not you
with me oh I like the treasure hunter
characters a lot coming I'm not going
whoa what is
happening what is
happening oh the police
oh you out
your oh [__] they were rebelling against
the cops has forced them into
it look out go go go go
oh you guys are like official criminals
now I got a head for you come
here this poor guy got thrusted into the
situation without wanting him all right
camer D good Jack his little brother
drowned in a cave when they were
young wow he's got to overcome yeah he's
got to overcome some trauma sometimes
caves fill up with water I'm really glad
that you're here I don't care I agreed
to your translator that's it I know I
didn't want to come down here I think
the character interactions get better
and better as this movie
goes the water too disgusting you guys
are all going to have
scabies I don't know what that
is I don't know what that iside is that
a thing I had no idea I think he was in
the
1600s good what is the water there from
this is
crazy that's hot candles there's people
in here hot candles huh hard right oh no
hot it's still hot like the people were
just lighting
it I corrected you no hard Greg gosh
wrong there's like a happen here that is
creepy what you love when boobs are in
[Music]
movies that was the same woman from the
club right it did look like her but I
apparently don't know who anybody
is nobody uses this Corridor why not
it's a bad place people who go in this
tunel don't come out this could save us
hours you think because you see
something in a Bo you know it they're at
a
Crossroads we had a friend named Lop he
lived down here for years he knew every
Corridor of every system except this one
there was something horrible down there
yo he's my favorite character well he's
very talented yeah he went inside and
nobody has seen him since so if you want
to take this way go
ahead I would rather take the safer
route yeah then that saves your hours
okay look at Zed and and use like him
all your legs and arms because there is
rats and the first bones now rats
everything
is
what I'm just
kiding go Z Z's funny dude I love
that slow and steady yeah what your hand
respect for keeping your flannel button
in a situation like this yeah oh I
wouldn't want my [__] to touch anything
what would freak you out more the bones
or the rats the rats me too and why is
that cuz the rats can crawl up your bum
hole or something oh my God why why
where my mind goes how loose is your
bum I think I'm
stuck can't
okay Sor just oh this poor guy CM down
it's okay no no no no I can't I can't
can't like when I
was look just just go just keep going
please just go breathe homie why are
they singing why are they singing this
oh no poor guy going to have
toj benj is someone behind him to push
him this is like in descent
yeah breathe breathe bab oh this is hard
to watch it does look like a it does
look like it's getting tighter is Just
My Mind Playing Tricks I think he's like
rotating or she's
rotating
that oh
no oh
no oh my God what is happening I think
it's
collapsing play cool now man play cool
did they make the right choice going
this one
wait tell me we didn't just go in a
circle this isn't here this is the same
tunnel
listen oh yeah that's helpful good hey
hey we are all tense right now let's
calm
down okay gra
sh there's no other option I really want
to know where they shot this do they
shot this at the actual catacombs
because the sets are awesome there's no
way right it is universal monus they
built some [__] it feels like
it what the hell is this oh that's a SI
sign oh my that's why they had it
Roxy are you a ghost I've never been
here okay what the hell is this then
people just tag your name on the wall I
swear I've never been here I didn't do
this okay who did it then I mean it's
awful suspicious you better not be with
us oh good there's a there's a phone the
walls are too thick I mean it's not a
cell phone it's clearly like a landline
thingy right what a landline the phone
company used to to run lines through
here but the L are here yeah well they
must have left some 50 years ago they
took everything I've been trying to
reach you for 50
years you think they're already dead and
this is hell oh good theory this is the
spot that I was talking about this is
where the buildings collapsed into the
ground hundreds of people fell to their
death right here oh that's why the bums
maybe it fell when one of the houses
collapsed yeah see like
there's spiritual transference of items
here Play It Again Sam Danny and I used
to play it all the time we only knew one
song My Bonnie Lies Over the Ocean oh
[__] is that one from his past the piano
from his past we could never finish it
cuz the A4 key wased up check if that A4
key
[Music]
up
it's pretty in
tune oh the is that the A4 key
yeah answer the
phone wait wait Scarlet this is an
intriguing mystery any
thoughts uh it does seem like some type
of hellish play on their past
[Music]
traumas
it's the popo we're the ones who tackled
your asses hello why want you talk to me
SC going to H up who is this is that her
dad who is
this why won't you talk to me scarlet
yeah it was her
dad
that's hope I thought you were dead
never even came to look for
me oh wow the M apparently yeah
everything just a big cacophony of
Horrors coming to life already you are
looking to get out yes
yes he is
creepy
wait there so
fast yeah okay so that must mean that
girl from the club is some
ghost okay is that bad it's not good
these sets are truly unbelievable that's
wild how can you see down here the only
way out is
down as above so below baby mhm mhm the
only way out is down dud I feel like
this this guy is just guiding
you to
your death moolly Moly Moly
oh
cool what they're going to rope down I
mean I would just dive and see what
happen head first into Oblivion you die
you maybe but maybe they're already dead
the East system and and the South system
of the Catacombs so try to connect them
if we find the chamber then then that's
the way out and it's down there what are
he's doing with his hands
is I am a little bit distracted by how
they're not trying to inquire with the
one guy like how are you alive just said
you never looked for me come on George
keep coming hold on I'm
stuck
whoa who fell on himie what happened
youie you okay oh man this guy is just
having a nightmare
situation fresh bandages this poor guy
he he's having it the worst the found
footage aspect got so much better when
we had more cameras now we can be in all
different places and actually feels well
Justified when yeah yeah but they needed
it cuz I would not want just one
person's perspective right now no guys
you need the
[Music]
audio whoa what's happening trippy I
can't
hear oh this feels reminiscent of the
beginning part of the
[Music]
movie Little clown boy [__] it's a dead
end you said this is the way I thought
it was the way
too this is why we didn't look for you
what come here oh my God
okay wind vure your way right as light
St Le your way oh [__] Are the evil
spirits guiding you to your answer I
know it feels secondary like maybe just
get out of
life Pharaoh Pharaoh Pharaoh uh didn't
pharaohs have some kind of a strange way
of of hiding the tombs can you just
explain what are you talking
about good question it's a sort of um
ancient Egyptian padlocks you have to
take the exact right Stone from the
exact right place or or what or you die
no or what the ceiling will collapse on
you and kill you what hell yeah the
swashbuckling continues the celestial
spars eight Planet but the last two
weren't discovered yet okay so six
planets don't touch anything was this
about before or after cicus really think
it through before you touch okay so they
still believe everything revolved around
the earth which means the Earth didn't
count as a planet right but but the moon
did i s to the Sun right so seven
planets right you guys might just have
time to sleep together stand way okay
out it's moving stand way the
back as if the ceiling
collapsing
hurry oh hell
yeah come on guys you got admit it's a
little exciting what are you see oh my
God oh my God what you have to see this
see
what is it a
bed is it a bed George's a mattress here
we can lay
down so they can bone he said
yeah he is not
likeing yeah exactly what he just said
he's not rotting or he's not a skeleton
they inbombed him but he should still be
like a corpse or you know what I mean
this has got to be the interior parts of
the earth no there's got to be more Wing
vulture leads your way with brightest
light and Darkest Day I like I like the
how the movie does keep this element of
Discovery though everyone turn off your
headlamps that there is a dead man right
there he's funny I reckon we can get
through
it that must be freezing there's a loose
start is it freezing towards the center
of the Earth
I don't know I would just use this as
the opportunity to pee if you were
holding it in you
know that would be
Savage no one's going to know they all
get in they're like
what wow what a fascinating visual the
treasure fire burning that's great use
of light in the in the The W how is
there fire burning n that's a great
question thank you I ask great questions
yeah you know law of
averages how are you possibly going to
haul even like a quarter of all that oh
my God he is so creepy you shouldn't
move the treasure you will be cursed how
are these torches still in the
philosopher soon can fuel a lamp for
eternity but that's a legend though yeah
this is reality the Earth good and the
sky goodest uhhuh were madly in love
when they had their first child the son
he became so jealous of their affections
that he pushed them apart so that they
were only able to touch by the palms of
their hands you okay it's all good
information every morning this guy got
his SK birth with the Sun every morning
and every evening she'd swallow him back
up that's it oh my God that's a
dedicated Mom it looks so ordinary so
how are the torch is
burning do we just suddenly believe in
the mythology I guess
so and this is when you're curs what
better place to hide the most valuable
stone ever known the next to riches you
could never miss you shouldn't be moving
it man wait stop it's the TR
stop
what have you guys not seen any
movies so this she has is the real
treasure apparently
man oh no not my girl
no oh
suie
probably are you hurt yeah
bro oh which person I think the creepy
dude they call him Lop we can't move the
Rocks we can't they're going to leave
him
again
might she's putting the stone on her
wait she is an
archaeologist I believe that's called
putting salt in the
wounds oh it's gone it's better no way
no
way it really
worked who did you do
that the is M do it to that other guy's
face so isy oh my God what happened if
you like licked it could you internally
heal some like what happened IFL sh it
up your ass yeah that's what I mean
there's things man you got to think
about put it in your pee hole see
finally you and I are on the same
page suppor Alica this is the door to
the mystical wait this is a door no no
that's a door no no no not exactly it
works in conjunction with this that's
not a door is it a door this doesn't
look like a door does thing a door let's
define what a door is first As Above So
Below oh let's go I said it it means
that what is within me is outside of me
as it is on Earth so it is in heaven
what does that mean English please so if
they carved a door on the ceiling
there's got to be a door on the
As Above So
Below oh
[__] this is a where is all that water
going wow she really knows this catacomb
situation better than the guy they
hired well I we'll give her credit for
it she's always willing to go first I
know there's a tenacity there's
leadership I don't know about leadership
she doesn't care about the lives as much
uh there's
management sales yeah there I would to
call leadership
but abandon all hope ye who enter here
oh okay according to mythology that's
the inscription over the Gates of Hell
call that well go in there I'm not going
in there thought you didn't believe in
any of this uh yeah when Magic Stone
heals damaged wound maybe you start
believing some
[__] that might change byebye yeah and
they should be made to crawl in their
bellies to enter the kingdom of darkness
yeah that occurred to me too
why would they want to go there they
need to find a way out I don't know if I
could see hell if I could like poke my
head in the door you would I mean I've
come this far I mean I guess there's no
other way
out hell's got some good art isn't that
the philosopher stone painting it's not
exactly the same it's similar though
it's a mirror of everything's a WR way
around it's the below
version UPS that's above so
below what the [__] what happened to the
entrance closed when they got in wow we
should just keep
moving [__] okay that boldness is just
take charge really good title to the
movie As Above So Below so the below is
like a a nightmarish hellish reflection
of it it's like the upside down just has
you always guessing what that
exactly how the extent of
that what is swallowing
[Music]
them shrill sound design in
this is this the rotten version of him
Jesus it is a rotten version of him
what's that heing so you think you can
tell Heaven from Hell take it Greg I
don't know what song Blue Sky from pain
not a Pink Floyd guy I like Pink
Floyd it's him there it's creepy guy he
he became Lucifer oh man if you're going
to go to hell him if you're become
Lucifer at least you're
ruling get back stay back stay back
careful careful he's like rabid he's
like a a haunted maze
character no suy no suy about to die
don't suie about to die don't touch him
going
[Applause]
die where is he where is he did he go
come
on the
stone why won't the stone work because
she's dead oh damn she is messed
up suie
at least she's going to be buried with a
bunch of other people sixy
canot that was my best joke
yet it's like a mirror image of what
we've already done right we just we keep
going deeper damn that sucks just keep
going deeper another 100 m 1,000 ft down
jeez how can you breathe I don't know
you know when you're H super high up and
it you can't what's what happens you
down you struggle for air too yeah down
yeah yeah yeah
you all right good oh
no where's a little kid I just wanted to
win a documentary award and here I
am you see it
yeah is he just byy himself here yeah
everybody else went down he's trying to
go down but he's waiting oh no oh that
actually got me that was scary oh
[__] Jesus who was the girl he saw was
it his friend that just had died I have
no idea no I don't think so do you think
any part of you would enjoy any part of
this at this point in this journey no no
not at this point why you you're I feel
like I would hope that I could find some
enjoyment in the fact you
drown dude that's his brother yeah do
you think I was right about the fact
that they're already in h yes brother
get
the get off the bones where do you want
them to go honey get off the bones float
no you got to realize not your actual
brother man he's still like the same age
he's like a kid man come
on so who do we have left and where's Z
tortured Souls where is Zed did he die
and we missed it no He's Alive where do
you see him I think he's the one holding
the camera oh good
boy fire I'm on fire up in here oh oh
[__] is that what happened with her dad
uh
I don't remember whose memory is this
hey it's that guy from the beginning it
wasn't my fault
oh
who
whoa damn the legs damn oh that was a
wild shot if you did not think you was
in hell you best believe it now so you
and I were both right
yes yes yes yes we we are smart
individuals what is it uh look like
someone with like an actual robe so is
it a combination of actual demonic
spiritual entities and cult Believers or
satanists down
[Music]
here oh someone should sit at the throne
maybe a bran nice
nice Arya if not
Sansa who is this is that supposed to be
the
[Music]
devil oh that is so creepy truly the
seven deadly sins plays on like the
souls trying to break through the
walls what is
that
whoa oh
oh stone stone stone
stone who's dragging him oh our friends
heal him with the stone baby I would not
love getting bit like that that is not
one of my preferred ways of being bit
either okay okay okay would the Stone
lose its power and effect here though no
it's good cuz Zed's going to die first
so we know this guy's going to be okay I
don't think so man it's working it's not
working I don't know I don't think it
works down here wow what V
vitalic there's another stone that works
down here there has to be rectification
this isn't the right Stone have to
rectify the taking of it only by putting
get back while I find the real Stone oh
God lady come on that was so obvious how
are you going to get back to that I'm
going
back I have to go back it was so obvious
but why did it work on that other girl I
think the further below you go the the
harder it is that poem
said oh get out of my way just like go
get out of my way boom
roasted damn this is a journey we're
going through all of this she just
climbing
up oh that girl the girl who killed him
yeah but I really thought that that girl
was socky
socky whoa is it just like a river of
blood
now whoa damn that actually got me oh
this looks like descent too where's her
camera in her hand all right oh I hope
she makes it
back oh man this guy who is this dude he
has coverage on his face her dad it's
her
dad Dad
yeah no I wouldn't take that off I would
just let it
be oh my God that was not her dad who
was that the girl whoa creepy what was
that what are we looking at there mouths
in the
ground oh I love how disorienting this
is you have to like really
focus holy B she made it how did she do
that the world will never
know I don't waste my time with chanting
I would just put it back where
turn everything's going to be all right
oh what is she looking at herself no
yeah no it's not her that is
her
me oh [__] it's first time we ever just
broke away from her as above so below as
I believe the world to be so it is hold
on
George oh movie giving you false hope
what is she doing she's trying to
retrieve him now but she doesn't have
the
stone yeah but she's trying to retrieve
him that is her
dad yeah sure take a bre sorry then
didn't pick up the phone that night a
very cool shot did didn't know you were
in that much pain didn't pick up the
phone phone was about about yeah I
didn't know you were in that much pain
he must have called her right
before so if you're able to make peace
with it it disappears kind of thing as
opposed to the other guy when he saw the
burning car he said it wasn't my fault I
didn't do it yeah should have made peace
Sor should have made peace you the
yes she is the stone oh true love's
first kiss is it is that what it
was how did you do that she is now the
stone because the mirror put it in her I
can't wait to look up an ending
explained on this I think that's what
happened she looked in it was her she is
the
stone let's see
it we'll never be able to climb down
that we have to jump what we have to
rectify ourselves I promised I might be
back with help my brother's drown
waiting for me to see
oh damn that sucks I think she's I've
never seen her you think she's already
dead I know it's mine but I did not eat
what did he say I think it's mine but I
denied before that
was
whoa all right they're coming to
acceptance of it all yeah but we don't
know what Zed thing was I will look it
up after while you're IMDb and frankly
we we couldn't even understand what he
was saying to be
that's a manhole find a grip find a grip
can you get your fingers in your
s oh man the editors of this movie had
fun what's happening right
now oh [__] what is that it's a manhole
to
Heaven it's the real treasure
hello
oh [__] is one of those things where
like go down then you're like coming up
like that yeah you got to go down to go
up hey creepy guy was right only way out
is to go more
below they're truly in the upside down
though yeah is he coming out feet first
oh yeah she I would have
jumped cool visual what is this a camera
that they threw up yeah and they wanted
to make sure they got it on camera so it
looked really cool
unreal shot that was very
cool no way are they surviving the
situation Now Zed has to die
so
wow how uncertain would you be though
that you were still alive I just can't
believe he's just walking away and what
about the person sitting there I'm not
doing this for financial gain I'm a
student of history of alchemy uhhuh so
you simply want the truth exactly and
you found it yeah I want the
truth wow they
lived they lived Roxy
maybe I think so wait hold on don't you
touch that don't you touch that dial we
could just go to imba yeah but I just
want to see man I want to see oh my God
fine Alex
hland while you're doing that
what while I'm doing that what I'm going
to look something up
Jesus that was a very interesting choice
for an ending of a movie that made so
many bold decisions and then it kind of
just like fizzled out like that I kind
of like it though
fizzled yeah kind of right like they
just like separated and hugged that was
the
end I mean they have a new chance of
Life they healed they had to let go of
their
pain I don't know who Ben Feldman is but
probably a Jew dude there's some good Ed
shut the [__] up it's the guy dude I'm
telling you I am telling you I think
it's that [__] guy from the movie
think you're right hold on hold on oh my
God you win but he really didn't look
like him once we got to the tunnels I
didn't think he was the same guy okay
hold on hold on what was this called As
Above So Below you really should know
the title but it I
know y Edwin hodj played Benji and he
was Bloody stranger yeah rocks let's go
I got one was I never get one it was
worth it for this moment right here I'm
right you're wrong I'm smart you're dumb
I'm big you're small and there's nothing
you can do about it what do you mean we
were on the same page they had to accept
their sins and then oh that's a line
from Matilda no I haven't seen Matilda
oh I'm talking about the OG
yeah havic I haven't seen either whoa
yeah you have to see
Matilda wish there was a YouTube channel
where I could take advantage of such an
opportunity to do that I'm not kidding
you should do that next maybe yeah
that's one of my list that's on my list
and then I'll do the musical with you I
haven't seen that okay cool that sounds
like a sweet time no retired all righty
guys well if you're listening to us on
Apple and Spotify we just watched asab
So Below we quickly looked up screen
rand's ending explain to make sure we
were on the same page and we were and we
were uh we did understand it apparently
I thought I didn't get it the part that
uh I spoke over the thing I get annoyed
at everyone else about for doing and I
am guilt this was my sin I've never done
video I turned to you and I went sh you
went sh you sh I'm trying to hear the
movie yeah something that she's never
guilty of inflicting here how do I
usually talk over important no yeah no
totally you don't you never do I never
have to adjust the edit for such a thing
I do that a lot no I'm not going to no
no you're
perfect I can tell your tone is forious
ble no no it's not what are you talking
about okay good is not good talk so I
think we should just move on from the
conversation you're everything you do is
amazing and there's no need for a
conflict okay so what happened was that
Zed apparently isn't seeing his kid so I
am curious about that part is that the
do daughter that we
saw uh yeah that's what I'm thinking the
one that look like a clown I don't think
it look like a clown I think it just
like smeared
makeup huh yeah cuz it was that's he saw
he saw the he no he saw the kid and then
the camera turned to him and he had the
look on his face like oh [__] yeah okay
but I I don't know I feel like if I'm in
a situation that be like that looks like
my daughter or is that my daughter so
let's think about the other characters
right but the part really quick I did
want to explain that we the part that we
did not draw a correlation to because I
don't think you've read it I haven't
read it apparently a lot of this riffs
on a book that I've heard the title of
many times and I here is a great novel
uh Dante's Inferno about the Nine
Circles and that's probably how many
times if we actually went back that they
were Ling themselves you're going
through the nine circles of hell and you
got to you know come face to face with
your sins and rectify it and the ones
who pretty much didn't take
accountability were the ones who uh got
the the boot so let's talk about the
ones who didn't take accountability okay
so obviously there's homeboy with the
good hair with the car yeah so he didn't
okay then let's talk about sexy soxy
suxy what happened with
suxy um I we don't know right she uh did
she uh I don't know something about
abandoning that guy the creepy guy okay
what about creepy guy I thought creepy I
thought they oh creepy guy's dead creepy
guy dead creepy guy's an apparition yeah
but what happened with him
he died because he didn't take
accountability for something and then
what about my dude from well he was no
he was already dead it's not that like
he was he was just an apparition
appearing
there their he died in the tunnels
though no uh he died on it might have
been the it might have been the tunnels
I think it was the tunnels we were
having a hard time understanding what
they were saying because um they weren't
speaking American you don't speak
American and then my guy from Purge MH
how'd he die
he fell from the thing because he got
confronted by this woman yes but what
didn't he make peace with God that's a
that's a fascinating question I think we
should look it up I think we should look
all this up Roxy fill the time we may or
may not know and they may not have
answers to that I think it's a good a
sign of a good movie when afterwards
you're thinking about it and you have
questions but it's also a sign of a
movie with some holes in it when
afterwards not everything fully aligns
and I think think like you Greg I think
that we care a lot about a movie
understanding its tone and while I think
for the most part this all stayed in one
realm the fact that we kind of dabble
with the supernatural but also want to
keep it so grounded but the thing that
happened with The Rock like it's
physical Stone which I can get behind
but then it's really inside you I was
like okay okay that's a choice all right
homie look I got it all I got all mapped
out here hold on a second hold on a
second let me just um let me just blow
this up for my own eyes blow up blow it
up watch all fall out I had a lot of
lyrics today yeah you did man we always
have the smoothest conversations don't
we we don't believe in silence we just
have to always fill the gaps with
conversation you know I feel like I'm
killing
it okay so Scarlet the main
protagonist we knew what her yeah we
knew that George George feels guilty for
the death of his younger brother Daniel
Benji okay Benji's the guy from Purge
feels guilt over a pregnant woman he
failed to help resulting in her death
this is subtly hinted at when a woman
with a baby cries out to him in the
catacombs oh we did hear that okay but
how did they yeah movie does not make
that abundantly C certainly not papon's
past is murky but he has a clear trauma
tied to a friend named L the mole who
was lost in the catacombs throughout the
film a vision of a burned man is seen
which is likely a manifestation of his
guilt associated with hoop that's what
the car situation was okay yeah Zen and
Su uh these characters specific censor
traumas are less overly explored in the
film compared to the others however they
are still subjected to the catacombs
nightm that's weird what are you talking
about what is sui I want to know what
suky sin that's the one thing I was
trying to find out we found out the
cameraman and Benji yeah we wanted to
know his yeah well no Benji the yeah
yeah yeah um um sui As Above So Below
what what was what's up I did I thought
I could like be awesome and like type it
typed what was in her I thought I could
be like hey that Paul Walker Too Fast
Too Furious over I did not
in really good God damn it Susy where
where is your name s okay oh oh my God
they're laying it out here sus sin is
yet another onp of the film what yeah
okay so to me like I thought that this
movie was was really interesting and I
was excited to talk to you about it
afterwards but I do think that they
could have gone a a little more with the
specifics and that would have taken it
from good to Great sure like there's
just there's some holes yeah well I like
a movie that makes you that compels you
to go back and rewatch it so that way
you can be like all right let me see if
I can pick up on like more of the clues
but already they they do lace out some
of their Clues although there is some
weird [__] in there there like the the
the person at the club right and then
but then we see them in the with the
yeah doing like a seance when they first
enter like those those worship people
who like turn to the camera like H are
you [__] here yeah we don't come back
to them yeah yes there's some there's
some things that are left dangling mhm
um the part with the the cop showing up
and then just dropping it was was a
little like I I guess I got lost in the
jarring of the the way it was being shot
so that would have been interesting if
something with the cop they were
actually almost getting into the layer
of hell so like if that had something to
do with somebody forgiving something
with a cop or whatever but it didn't I
think that that was real right right
okay so that must have been their first
layer of hell like the second they
entered the the the terrain maybe
yeah yeah then they have like other
creatures and stuff I like the depict of
hell I think the way that hell is
depicted is really cool here it did seem
hellish it's very visually aesthetic
it's not just a bunch of like Inferno
stuff you know it's not just Flames like
it it feels like Souls trapped in a
variety of ways variety is a spice of
life variety is a spice of life thank
you Roxy there's a lot of decomposing
bodies there's uh I like the the the the
stuff where they were like trapped in
the walls like they you know what I mean
with the the stone W yeah those were
very cool yeah the the sets in this
that's the other thing we wanted to look
up where they actually shot don't worry
man look I'm I'm I got it homie those
sets were really truly wild really wild
I do wish you you know I'm lover of Love
shipper of ships I do wish that we got
to see our two main characters make out
at the end yeah me too man uh on
location let's see how you actually do
here I don't remember what I
let's see how you're doing don't look
what I sayne they film as above so blow
on location at
on what was the at on it's all shot on
location at Paris oh okay let me ask
okay with permission from the it was
shot in the real I was going to say like
I was like there's no way they just
built all this stuff for a found footage
movie I just can't believe that they
were given permission to do that I mean
it creates a tourist attraction site man
they obviously had the tour guide
element here and I think that was just
it made me as a viewer go it would be
cool if it was a way to like visit some
of this that'd be awesome it'd be
stressful to film there I can imagine an
that adds to the actors yeah for sure
for sure uh I thought the acting was
really good so solid um all of them
across the board but especially I
thought that French
dude Li handsome man handsome Panic guy
yeah the French
F he was he was were all really
phenomenal really really well cast um
and I I actually gave a [__] about them
which is funny because we're talking
about how little we knew about them but
there was something about their
personalities that shown through in a
way that I was like every time one of
them died I was like oh man I'm going to
miss that person I do I do I do think
that like in the beginning it was very I
could I could actually hear the
screenplay and and normally would found
footage that's the last thing you want I
think once they actually got to meet the
the treasure treasure hunter French
people when they're just like chilling
in the van and as they keep going along
you feel some of the Improv coming to
life and I didn't actually hear a like
the only it was only in the beginning
when I I could the first before they met
with them that I could actually see the
text of the screenplay and then here and
then at that they reach a certain point
where oh now it's becoming like what you
want from a f footage movie where it it
just feels natural and people are just
listening to actual people talking I
agree with you I think that there was
more dialogue early on too and like and
then it kind of spoke for itself the
further we got just kind of watch feel
more like fly on the wall which is how
you want to feel in found footage do you
do you like this movie like do you think
this was solid do you think it was great
uh I was aware that it had terrible
reviews and like rotten tomatoes or
critics or audience or critics let's
find out um I can never stop Googling
never stop that's
that's what we do oh my God D oh [__]
watch I could I could type as above so
below without without looking to do look
up I
[__] you can do
it
h as a buff I got most of it right I was
pretty close manal I yeah but it was
good so below I'm pretty close good
enough that it's the first thing that
popped up oh my God yeah it's really low
um
I definitely liked it more so on the
Tomato Meter it's 28% and audience is
40% I definitely am closer to the
audience than the Tomato Meter but I
liked it more than that I think that
this was good I would say I I would give
it like if I were to increase it I would
say that I'm more closer to like a 65 to
70% on this movie I might go a little
higher than that actually yeah totally I
could definitely see this be it was like
a c for sure okay this is fascinating to
me because it's saying after intriguing
setup that threatens to claw its way out
of found footage Overkill plummets into
cliche mediocrity I completely disagree
with that I I want the exact I'm like
all right setup sure but it feels
artificial and then I thought it became
more intriguing as it went and it got
better as it went yeah I'm super with
you and I loved the craziness the
cacophony of just hellish nightmarish
demonic um religious cultish
Vibes that it just kept throwing at us
it was a cataclysm of just craziness
that was spewing out I I thought it was
cool I thought it got really cool 28% is
so low is really bad you know what I
wonder though if that has to do with the
fact that this came out in 2014 and this
is more of like an it has more of an
indie horror Vibe and I feel like that's
a lot more popular nowadays for
Universal in Lion's gate damn what like
you're saying it's not really Indie cuz
it's
I'm not saying it's an indie movie it
has an indie vibe to it in terms of like
the found footage aspect of it makes it
feel like it's not you know it's not a
major monster movie it's like uh even
some a lot of those like a24 neon movies
um yeah of course they are more Indie
but this had to me actors I don't know
um like it was not I guess the
location's big budget and that's what
keeps it from being an indie and
obviously it's backed by Major Studios
but when you're watching it this didn't
feel more Indie to you no it it felt a
little bit more like a studio made a F
footage movie yeahuh I've seen a good
amount of found footage movies I think
I've only seen Blair Witch oh my God
there's some good ones out there have
you seen wreck no balls amazing what are
other ones you know paranormal activity
no you haven't seen paranor activity why
have you not spoken these
words is that a line from the no no I'm
saying why speak these words my way I
don't know I didn't know is it a big one
it's like the biggest one oh after BL
witch oh I haven't seen it I haven't
seen you haven't seen paranormal
activity no it's good it's really good
that's like pure Indie so maybe that's
why I did like this a little more eight
of them or something really maybe that's
why it feels Indie more Indie to me even
though it's not because I'm not used to
found footage movies really oh my God
there's one this oh an exorcism one I've
never seen The Exorcist um that's a good
movie it's not is that fan Fage no it's
not uh no what what is I can't remember
the name of it it was a really good one
had the guy from better colol anyway uh
but this movie oh my God I just put
together what that poster is you see the
poster it's the Eiffel Tower upside down
upside down and then the C and then the
skulls oh that's a clever
poster good I like the red yep I like
red I like red
red red is red is a color red red is
good red is horor um I do take gripe
from a storytelling perspective though
of I didn't
think I yes what is happening gripy
Greg gripey Greg over here gripy Greg
what
he I do have a I do have a grud
with it felt like once she realized they
had to get over stuff it was a task and
not a true acceptance yeah she was just
like so what is it that's up with you
okay good let's jump yeah and even for
her in that moment it's like there's I
get there's no time to have a real
moment cuz cuz hell is literally caving
in on them um but it was oh I got get my
dead dad situation
hey I love you all right got to go kiss
this guy uh I'm with you I think that
that definitely could have been done
better yeah that to me that felt very
rushed and and and while it was like a
bit of an obvious turn like that's it's
a horror movie thing like yeah you must
come to Acceptance in order for to
escape it uh I I understand I think
there's a handling of that that you have
to be a little bit more gentle with not
to make you Google more but can you look
up the budget this oh dude no I I would
be more than happy to uh constantly
interject Googling okay yeah [__]
this all right what is the production I
know I [__] up already of As Above So
Below you didn't write budget oh you did
produ dude I only messed up the word
production okay five
million I think what they did for $5
million it grossed 41 million what they
did for $5 million with this I think
that they with those locations and
everything yeah I thought that they did
a really solid job they did yeah I'm
surprised with how uh [__] that this
perform with the critics and the
audience in terms of reviews it making
$41 million shows that people are
obviously still interested well you got
understand did I bore you no no no I'm
just a just little sleep depress so you
have to also understand that it came out
at a time when found footage
movies uh people were like getting sick
of them they started hating the genre it
was very common in yeah there was a time
where there was just it just wouldn't
stop like Paranormal Activity kicked off
just so many found it just was an
onslaught of found footage so it's just
sort of got lumped into this camp that
they're all the same and and and I think
it's it was an easy target for found
footage and uh yeah I just feel like if
this came out today it would have done
better I don't know I think so too I
think I think it's a I think it's a it's
Little Indie profound footage it's
little Universal Lions get Indie
fil for for for found footage it's I
think it's effective and it gets the job
done and uh it got better as it went and
I I like that unlike most found footage
movies I it actually had this like lore
and mythology to it that you kind of
wanted to unpack as it went yeah a 28 is
egregious it is like if you see that you
don't watch the movie and that's
ridiculous like this is so far from
being at 28% on the Tomato Meter it's
insane yeah cuz it's well crafted and
sure you get p and I think also you know
for the most part there was justified
with the cameras I don't know who edited
it I don't know who went back and edited
all this footage what I mean I don't
know who the film I don't need to know
who the film editor of as of EP So Below
is I'm talking about in the world
obviously zad bro Z was just like that's
why he left them he like I got edit I'm
to start editing cuz the cameraed
everybody your car things I need your
emails and you just sign off on this app
and how did Zed end up getting the
footage of the people that didn't make
it out alive that's what I mean was
there a cloud who was being uploaded to
how was this put together it is a very
fascinating question to me the year is
2014 so maybe they did have have you
seen quarantine that's a not quarantine
uh
Cloverfield um does it have very famous
people in it n Cloverfield 19 or
something 14 there's 10 Cloverfield Lane
that is the sequel I saw that oh you
didn't see the first one the found
footage one in New York with the monster
wait what's the one that's underground
is that's 10 Club field I saw that okay
good the first one's a found footage
movie did I see it is it same people or
no know let me run a little science
experiment and go into your brain and
see tell you you have SE it after
spending millions of dollars to go into
your brain um is it the same actress or
no no it's a completely different movie
I don't think I saw it all right well
that's a movie
um yeah I think I missed all the the
only time I saw Blair Witch I saw it
once I was a kid on my way to Salem on
the school bus they played
it that's a boring movie I hate that
movie I liked it when I was a kid on the
way to Salem it was cool I think it's
the most overrated movie okay if if
someone were to ask me what is the most
overrated movie in your in your personal
opinion I would instantly say Belair
Witch Project really instantly wow I do
not understand mine is Phantom
thread it's not like a phenomenon in
that movie what everybody loves it it is
super pretentious and not great it's
because it's the the director and Dan de
Lewis yeah I'm not I just and it's his
last movie are you trying to fight with
me about it no I'm just saying that's
why it's that's why it's hyped I haven't
even watched the damn I'm just saying
that's why it's hyped yeah yeah but
people love it over it you got to like
it because they're very respectful
you're standing up for a movie you
haven't seen bro I let you have Blair
Witch I like that as a kid well I you
can respect my opinion but you're a
woman so I'm going to tell you how to
feel uhhuh you're um you are footage
explaining
[Laughter]
me tell me more about Paranormal
Activity BL witch um yeah and uh I think
I think we beat the points to death good
use of sound design I got to point that
out great use of sound design and um
that that would really help for their
moments where they did not have a budget
to like we need a crazy amount of
collapsing to happen but we can't show
it on camera I got it let's just go
really Jagged with the way the camera is
moving a lot of crazy motion and then uh
little flashes of things just a lot of
sound design and then people will really
think but you know I thought it was
really I thought they they they handled
that very well yeah I agree with you
completely and I really like the setup
of a of a I like the idea of like an
Indiana Jones Laura Croft Tomb Raider s
kind of character Tom Holland from
Uncharted going in and being like I got
to go through this archaeological underg
Adventure yeah I think people were way
too harsh on this to me any movie where
the performances are Stellar is at least
a 50 like at least decent it's got a
higher Google user rating it's it's you
it's got a higher Google user
rating do you see what I have to a
reasonably High imtp rating I'm very
tired oh it does 86% on Google 6.2 on
that's actually that's actually not
that's not not
bad all right Roxy you want to close out
yeah thank you guys so much for being
above while we were below
definitely and that was probably as good
as it's going to get so as good as it
gets like comment subscribe and if you
want me to watch paranormal activity
then let Greg know yeah I don't know how
we'd find somebody else who hadn't seen
it though it sounds like a
challenge it's a challenge to resist
tempation okay that's my last lyric for
today
[Music]
bye